mean I first started getting into
property in August 2021 and I never had
any intentions to get into real estate
but when I found out you could get in
with no money I thought this is it
you'll ever get a normal job no I just
couldn't I don't understand how I could
put 40 hours a week every single week in
a month and then earn only two
grandmother I've just sold one deal and
I made three grand me 19. did you find
that was a problem if I was coming on
property courses like a crash course so
many people come up to me and say you're
only 19. I wish I was your age when I
started but then when I go into the real
world and I'm trying to speak to
landlords and agents it looked at me and
think what would you know about property
every single week it was almost an
embarrassment I was getting embarrassed
because after four months you hadn't
done a deal you were getting embarrassed
because everybody else was getting deals
and you weren't and it was a struggle I
had this expectation I should be getting
a deal now but I wasn't getting it until
you kind of give me a kick like you've
got one month only here bro you made it
yes it's been a long journey it has
because we started working together when
you were how old I was 19 at the time
19. and now you're 21. yes I read a book
written by the leader of a church who is
a prophet and it was about real estate
and I never had any intentions to get
into real estate but when I found out
you could get in with no money I thought
I need to research into this further and
that's when I came across your channel
and I attended my first ever crash
course in 2021 September I remember that
and I remember saying to you why are you
here when you said you wanted time to
focus on Mission you wanted to go into
full-time Ministry in the church and I
thought I like this guy you know he had
a good energy and um but the thing is it
was it was quite a tough start and you
had some challenges which we'll get to
but what happened at that crash course
where you spent one day with me the sort
of like started all this what happened
that day crash course it's just like I
just saw endless opportunities and I
think your energy really really just
made me think this is it this is what
I've been looking for because at the
same time I didn't want to go to
university anymore either because I
wasn't doing the course I wanted to take
in the first place and then of course I
was doing was Pharmacy which I
absolutely hated and I was like not cope
with this for another three four years
yeah because what happens at the end of
my first year I failed one exam that
held me back for another year but
however it gave me the time to look into
something else and of course that
sometimes I need to get into property
now interesting I wonder how many
teenagers or young adults right now are
studying something at Uni and they don't
even want to go into the profession that
they're studying yeah I mean I have
friends who are still in University and
they're always complaining to me we hate
University it's too many long hours and
I'm there like you should just get into
property yeah right and then even when
they finish units then they've got the
job that they don't want and then
they've got to climb the corporate
ladder get to the top of the corporate
ladder and realize that they're on the
wrong ladder yeah it's funny because I
actually remember when I was working at
your job um and somebody had said to me
what do you want to get into and I was
like I'll do pharmacy for a couple of
years but then on again to real estate
at that point I didn't know much about
real estate and one thing that she said
to me was quit now we're wasting your
time just get into real estate now 100.
and I've said the same thing if someone
said to me I'm doing real estate because
I want to make a bit of money but then
ultimately I want to be a photographer
I'll be like well hang on don't do
property now you want to start climbing
an ladder of the one that you want to
get to the top of and the thing is your
property is whereas it gives you active
income but also passive income so you've
now got time Freedom where you're
getting very involved in Ministry and
doing the things that you feel
passionate about yeah for sure and it's
just like I don't have to waste every
single day nine till six doing work that
I don't enjoy in fact even if I was to
spend long hours doing property I enjoy
it so much that it's like I can continue
how much have you made in the last few
weeks in the last few weeks I've made
five grand that's pretty good is that a
lot more than you your friends make it
you know they don't they don't make
anyone yeah yeah so how are you making
money in property because when you
started you said that you didn't really
have much money at all to invest yeah I
mean
near zero that's the best way to put it
yeah but of course as I learned the
strategies and how to get in
when I got my first winter and I did it
as a JV with my dad so he put the money
in and then of course we worked together
on it and now I just manage the property
gave him half and I take half the
profits and you know that's so perfect
because then you don't put your penny
money in you used him probably for the
references and for the as a guarantor I
actually do I need a guarantor for that
one how come it's directly landlord and
the landlord funny enough with this
landlord he was ready to give it to me
until he saw my company was new and I'd
already said oh it's a sister company of
Samuel is limited and he said to me I'll
give you a chance but only because I
know Samuel leads and he's got a good
track record so wow I think just because
you had that good track for a good help
me get my first deal over the line
amazing and he never asked for a
guarantor I had basically two months
rent free period yeah so there was also
no deposit of front either damn so what
did you need your dad for then what did
he pay for it was just a refurb it
needed a quite a bit of like um cosmetic
work doing and stuff like that and
because it's my first property it's
quite daunting yeah because I didn't
know what I was doing even though he's
like I've been through the training or
listen rehab it's like okay what do I
actually do yeah some guidance yeah you
felt like having your dad on when you
refurbing the property just to give you
that sort of bit of extra support
definitely and you know I needed that
help because there was a lot of work and
to be honest with my dad did for quite a
lot of work into getting that refurbed
quickly as well how much did the refill
cost only about two grand to be honest
we managed to get it done cheap but if
you had got it done from somewhere else
let's say you know got painters in and
builds and whatnot it could have been
double Yeah Yeah so basically because
you spent two grand on the house you
were able to negotiate with the landlord
look I'm making your house better yeah
so you paid no deposit no upfront rent
you didn't need references or anything
like that he was happy he knew me yes we
were working together that's the power
of Association before going into all the
success because I know now you've got
you know your rent to rent your deal
sourcing you're making good money I want
to talk about the struggles and the
challenges because it was let's face
every single week it was almost an
embarrassment yes because I was getting
embarrassed because after four months
you hadn't done a deal yeah and I was
like oh this is awkward you're on a
12-month program you're not getting a
deal you were getting embarrassed
properly because everybody else was
getting deals and you weren't and it was
a struggle so talk to me about the
struggle yeah so as I joined the academy
and stuff I thought this is it I'm gonna
be able to do it but I think there was a
lot of elements I lacked myself
I thought I was putting enough work in
but compared to what I do now it was
absolutely nothing and sometimes you can
join The Mastermind calls think you're
doing enough but sometimes you have to
take a step back and ask yourself am I
really doing enough I was very
inconsistent with my hours as well how
many hours is putting in but then it's
like I had this expectation I should be
getting a deal now but I wasn't getting
it until you kind of give me a kick like
you've got one month if you don't get a
deal I'm coming to punch you in the
throat and I think I needed a kick and I
think that's just the way I worked oh
surely I didn't say anything that
extreme it was it was on a Monday last
night
yeah in front of 150 odd people and I
remember everybody in the comments being
like we're gonna remember this we're
going to remember this get it written
down wow and I think the thing is as
well listen I I coach everybody
different you'll see this sometimes
people are struggling they need a bit of
a cuddle they need their arm around them
sometimes people need a you know a
clearer plan and sometimes people just
need
to be threatened yeah you know like
you're gonna be I'm gonna come in your
house and punch you in the face bro like
you have to and it's not one of the
things I say to people is I'll say act
like if you don't get a deal this month
you will die yeah because the reason
people don't get deals usually
especially when they're on the academy
and they've already got the environment
and the training the network is because
they're not putting in the hours yeah
for sure and like you said they tricked
themselves because a lot of people I
don't know if you did this they make two
or three calls and they go a bit bad and
then they're like oh but it feels like
they did loads of work but actually if
they look at their call history they're
on the phone for a minute each yeah
three minutes work and then they're like
on The Mastermind saying oh I've called
loads of landlords and nobody wants to
rent to rent in Birmingham it's like
hang on you spent three minutes on this
and you trick yourself totally and then
I know after the eviction as well like
the work that people put into that the
tasks how did that potentially help you
it really opened my eyes when I saw the
amounts of hours we were working on the
eviction and I saw the way people work
it was like this is different yeah I was
at 12 o'clock and ready to sleep and
Cheryl's like no we've got a lot of work
to do and we'll work until five four or
five a.m and I'm like okay this is so
different to the work ethic I expected
and it was such an eye-opener it's like
this is how I need to be working if I
did this exact same thing with my
business I'd be getting so far wow and
then very quickly thereafter I got my
service accommodation right after that
one was in negotiations for a month so I
basically found it straight after the
eviction but then after negotiating for
a month and getting things set I'm
managing myself accommodation then
that's amazing and that was wrong with
your dad this one I actually I loaned
the money oh because she's not the same
one you're talking about a minute ago so
that one was a HMO which I'd got
um back in April but this one I've got
in August and this is a service
accommodation and the thing is joint
ventures are good but for me it felt
like the income I just wanted more so so
then ibby who's actually on the academy
well was on the academy and is one of
the mentors now yeah he said to me why
do you just loan the money he goes that
way you'll be giving less of your
profits away as well and you know you'll
be able to pay back quite quickly
because I knew Birmingham is an area
that 100 work and he helped me with the
numbers as well and we was easy looking
at low season between 800 to 1.2 K and
it's like you'll be able to pay that
back off in about three four months why
are you gonna join Venture so
effectively rent to rent is when you
rent a property and then you rent it out
at a higher amount with all the correct
permissions and contracts and
legislation in place on average you
might make 500 to a thousand pounds a
month on the road to rent I know you're
doing a little bit more than that
because you've really cracked it so
that's what rent to rent is you can do a
rent to HMO you can do a rental service
accommodation but the thing is even when
you're doing your rent to rent you still
need usually a little bit of money
Furniture yes up front rent a deposit
contracts there's a few thousand pounds
generally that you might need to put
into into the deal so what you're saying
is you can either joint venture with
people you can loan the money why don't
you talk to me about some of the ways
that you can get the money together for
rent to rent yeah so another thing which
is something I'm looking into is doing a
resort is find passive investors there
are a lot of people who have money
sitting in their Bank
and they just wanted to grow they don't
want to do anything with it they're not
really too concerned they just want a
little bit of Returns on their money so
one thing I'm looking to do is give them
eight to ten percent of the profits each
month but make them put the money up
front and then after however long let's
say a year give them the initial amount
back that way I get to keep a lot more
and more profits and I can invest in a
lot more property deals instead of using
my own money yes I'm making money
through deal sourcing but if I keep
putting my own money in it's going to
take a lot longer yeah to scale up and
then compared to having investors and
you can also sell a deal and then use
the profits to invest in a rental you've
just I mean I know you've been pretty
successful at deal selling as well what
are you talking about what deal selling
is and how you do that deal selling is
simply where you find a deal a good
property deal you package it up get all
the information together and then you
find an investor who's looking for that
deal and then you pass it on to them for
a fee so the way I did it was I actually
did it bespoke so I had an investor in
place already the investor told me look
I need a rental service accommodation
birmingham's e-center I know a lot of
people struggle with Birmingham city
center because I've you know worked so
hard over the last few months I built so
many connections and so many people are
just ready to give me deals and then I
was like okay I will find you a deal and
we had an eight week time period and
this one's quite interesting because I
found the deal we're ready to move
really really quick on it and then I get
a phone on the day saying oh we've
actually given it to somebody else after
I'd viewed it patched it investor was
happy and they said oh somebody else is
going to take it but then I get a phone
call a month later whilst I'm driving
and it's like oh that property it's just
come available again are you still
interested I told my investors that yes
I want it within about three days
everything done dusted money in the bank
sorted how much did that deal get you
three thousand pounds three thousand
pounds the magic number so how's life
different now then from say a year or so
back a year or so back it was like
you know I didn't know what I wanted to
do you know after I felt like one exam
and I was told yes you're gonna have to
do it at the end of another year
everybody's moved up a year and I'm
behind it felt quite daunting and coming
from an Asian background as well there's
this expectation you have to get a
degree you have to do this everything
systemized yeah it's funny because a lot
of people from my background when they
came into this country first they always
had a business and that's how they got
rich yet they'll push their kids into
jobs which I'll never understand and so
going from thinking I've let my parents
done what am I going to do with my life
and now my parents have seen the money
that is coming and they're themselves
they're like yeah I leave University Wow
have you left yet so I left in September
fantastic that's amazing and now you
don't need a job anyway no I don't
you'll ever get a normal job no I just
couldn't I don't understand how I could
put 40 hours a week every single week in
a month and then and only two grand one
I've just sold one deal not had to do as
many hours and I made three grand yeah
that's right and I'm passively making
about you know about
exactly and I'm not putting in more than
five to seven hours a week in total on
them it's just like why would I do 40
hours a week so the hard work the
initial sort of fork because it was only
four months but it felt like four years
didn't it because every week on The
Mastermind we'd be facing each other
obviously
how's it going Ricky I'm struggling a
bit and I literally spent time you
remember when I was like listening to
you on the calls you were recording your
calls yeah you were getting better
you're putting the hours in what advice
would you give to somebody who's maybe
gone out there stepped out in faith to
do property quit their job join the
academy or they're just like yeah really
going for it but then they're like oh
man
few weeks in even a few months in
they're not getting the results that
they hoped what would your advice be as
someone who's been there I think my
first piece of advice would be don't
compare yourself to anybody else I think
that's one thing that I really did would
constantly brought me down it's like
this person during the academy same time
as me yet they're getting way more deals
than me why is that and another thing is
don't trick yourself into thinking
you're putting the work in when you're
not be ready to put the hours in it
might feel like silly hours at the start
but once you have those Venture events
systemized let's say you know my accept
accommodation all I have to do is send
them the instructions that's all I do
and it's not much and then Thermo clean
is what day you have to go in so really
I'm not putting in many hours into our
service accommodation at all but
initially you have to put the hours in
and that's the only way you'll get your
property deals because I know it's not a
competition but it's about who's the
fastest to get those deals as well yeah
and I think that's why it's about
working smart and hard but at the
beginning you've got to work smart and
hard yes and now you're just working
smart what are your plans for the future
within property I know that you're
wanting to use your property income to
go into Ministry which is you are
beginning to do now which would be great
to hear about but property terms what's
the plan so in terms of T I really
enjoyed this accommodation side but then
I thought this combination way better
until I realized his pros and consists
accommodation even with hmos but I think
I was probably stick to service
accommodation and just scale up the
business I really want to be able to
systemize it and then when I've got
a few more enterments then I really
would love to go into BRS and stuff
because eventually I do want to go into
property development yeah no she's
following the pattern bro yes that's it
you could become financially free get
rent to rent and do deal sourcing don't
need a job then use the money to build
your wealth and then get gripped by a
mission which you dedicate your life on
talk to me about your mission within the
ministry yes so my mission is basically
that I really want to be able to serve
in church full time
um I mean I first came to Christ in May
2021 and it all started with my sister
who was a Christian and she passed away
in May 2021 and that really hit hard
because
it was like because she was a Christian
I'd kind of distanced myself until I saw
the love that the church had given to us
as a family and supported us through
these times it really touched me and it
made me think look at the way these
people have supported us yet I don't
know them and the humility they had us
all like the leader of our church
imagine they had the humility to come
over that day when things happened and I
just thought there was some local church
ladies and just to find out afterwards
they've got a net worth of over 200
million there's some rich people and yet
the support the love they showed it
really touched me and it's like I really
want to be able to support people the
same way that's amazing bro and I think
that I said this when I first met you I
remember almost prophesying over you
with property I said you're going to be
extremely successful and I could see you
had a fire there and that's as well why
I was so determined you know
that's probably why I said I'll come and
put you in the front because I'm just
like this guy has to win but you know
it's absolutely incredible with your age
being 19 starting out did you find that
was a problem did you find out you were
getting a objections about your age was
it an advantage talk to me about that I
think it was mixed I mean if I was
coming on property courses like a crash
course so many people come up to me and
say you're only 19. I wish I was your
age when I started but then when I go
into the real world and I'm trying to
speak to you landlords and agents they
look at me and think he's a young man
like what would you know about property
kind of thing yeah if I go into an
agency and I'm like yep I'm looking for
a brr deal up to anything up to 150k
cash I'm happy you know sometimes look
at me like do you even have 150k on you
and it does put you down at times but
then you gotta remember there's somebody
who's going to be willing to give you an
opportunity one that worked in my
advantage was a service accommodation
that I got first I seen very
I'm not sure what's the correct word to
use but they weren't really showing
compassion let's say until they realized
that I'm young on their son's age and
have a similar mentality to him and then
they were like you know what take this
one and in fact we've actually got
something else coming for you as well so
they're ready to give me another one
very soon as well wow so you kind of
just have to keep going and flip the
cards use everything to your advantage
um what's it been like working just
despite the punch in the throat comment
what's it been like working with me and
and what's your experience been like of
the academy this far it's been really
good I mean coming from an environment
where I'm around University people who
just want to go out clubbing drink into
being surrounded by Millionaires and
people who just want to be successful in
life and have a mission it was such a
massive upgrade I could never go back to
in that environment you'll never see me
in those places either it's like I need
to be around these people if I want to
be successful
have to be around these people and one
line that's always stuck with me which I
think is you who said it and it was your
environment is greater than your
willpower and that has stuck with me
from the start man it's like I need to
make sure I'm in the right environment
and I think that's a massive reason why
I wanted to join the academy as always
like if I get myself in that environment
there is no way that I could not be
successful yeah but you've been
extremely successful but I know that
this is the very beginning and not only
are you going to go on to make a load of
money I believe you're going to help a
lot of people so big respect my brother
thanks for coming on the show thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]